from show-stopping performances to
emotional acceptance speeches here are
the most memorable moments from the 2018
American Music Awards
[Music]
it was a history-making night for Taylor
Swift who broke Whitney Houston's record
for most wins by a female artist girl
power was a huge theme of the night as
Camilla Kibeho Jennifer Lopez Mariah
Carey Carrie Underwood dual eepa LMA
Ciara and Missy Elliott Halsey and cardi
B all slayed the stage
[Music]
another highlight stars encouraging
everyone to make their voices count you
can go to vote gov like Taylor Swift
told you to Tracy Ellis Ross hosted the
show where she gave us her best cardi B
impression and eyewitness in the
audience tells ET Cardin wasn't her
usual enthusiastic self during Tracy's
rap
we're told she stayed seated during the
opening number we also got a rare public
appearance from Macaulay Culkin it is so
great to be here to present this next
award and perhaps the most emotional
moment of the night rapper xxx 10th
osteon who was killed in June won the
award for favorite soul R&B album his
family accepted on his behalf
I am honored to accept this award on
behalf of my son I would like to thank
the AMAs his fans and to everyone who
made this possible thank you guys so
much I appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]